he ups and downs who saw that the first
half see it all season gear falls down
as Anya put defense there at Knox comes
up to steel head - Nikita Nikita steps
up for Grilli that's good
[Applause]
the next snap is Hardaway head up mudiay
to the neophyte with the sweet stuff so
nice and short twice the ramp agent
Knicks now thriving and transition then
strikes this pass inside deflected
knocks got a piece of it it's like the
third try no wrong prints ghastly
passing by him that's the fifth turnover
already hard way again to the basket
very well in this game off to that
trouble getting on the pick-and-roll
there
[Music]
[Applause]
why share the pic and rolling in we're
reaching in and watch the coats and
Lenox excuse me not election to latex
Burke's jumper yeah - that's - the
buttons that have an open TC Paul George
all militina with another nice defensive
play here comes Knox goes it's elton
layup is good and the foul Oh Kevin ox
good aggressive drive to the basket get
some easy buckets outside Frank with the
block previous play deflection there
then dots I like how he was slow and
composed took his time the final five
was presented by four
maybe on the drive gets underneath house
reverse laughing Ron Baker Milton fires
and mrs. Knox running the floor catches
throws it down that time the pass on
point from Ottawa the eyes wide open
previously knocks mr. Dahle you
let's--oh kicks it out play on Lopez
rise it is surprising in with the block
shot we never sleep but India fights
that time to get City who beautiful feed
from Emmanuel mudiay to Kevin Knox from
three talked about hood he's been here
tonight food whoa watch it away yeah
let's take a look at Knox resounding
rejection look at the rebound booty
ain't Dutch look up here's thoughts
slapped upon on the theme from booty and
the Hornets on fire from their towns
seventh of
from three-point range and knocks into
three at the buzzer at the other end the
next one Baker yesterday with a sign
clear to an NBA deal roadway peel she's
getting a piece of that
here's Hardaway pulls up and connects
still a basket and finish Kevin that's a
good aggressive move he's got nine point
okay hey the Skycam bill
Knox comes out with it here's where Knox
loves the open floor goes right at work
massive knocks it down
Devon Knox with a beautiful move to the
basket he's got ten points here in the
first quarter at the other end
yeah he's not charging into the defender
Mike he's reading the defense that's
tatak lost it ball tip taken by mudiay
throws it ahead to Hardaway
Hardaway throws enough to Knox ha ha
beautiful
alley-oop and a rookie throws it down
and awarded with a couple free throws in
that lane struggles complete recently as
hard as was a bad pass Knox with the
steal 48 may have gotten away with a
trap hold the Tanner gets up at in it
next there's the other way
[Applause]
the first water Kevin Knox one 1/4 best
quarter in the knick uniform he lit up
the garden welcome home Kevin the bucket
and it was just the floodgates opened up
comments mishandles a pass to latina Don
horses done a terrific job just putting
the rice pieces together slides it over
to canter while a hesitant to take the
three knots good ball fake let down and
hits the jumper as the shot clock
winding down
doclock game clock difference about four
seconds to the shoot not just gonna have
to get it off just get some time to time
tough shot the hole finally with six
rebounds brendan gears knocks and it's
good Kevin box foul by Hernan Gomez hits
the shot a shot off contact about 10
feet away but what a pretty shot high
off the glass so the evolution of a
rookies start to understand there's not
space it inside it's cut it and the foul
so Kevin ox with another opportunity for
a three point look as he gets a hard
drive to the left
takes the contact
[Music]
knocks gets past Simmons goes right
Arizona and Linux with their first weeks
of a period in a took um almost six
minutes and a dramatic way to break a
drought but he leaks his own earlier
showing another aspect of his game will
pocket pass
Oxana need to put up three-pointers not
[Applause]
[Applause]
obtained in a tray from the Celtics
knocks who's been quiet tonight able to
get that one to go and the foul so
chance for a three-point play for the
kid not six nine
has been a problems for them especially
without Clint capela deflect that gets
it back
[Applause]
[Music]
trios nila kita knocks the drives nice
shot from Max he's got 12 points
simulation about fun well Hornets though
aren't back defensively
knocks Jeff step three Potter is good
Kevin Knox now with 14 23 and here's
Mario on the break up to Knox nice
little step in and one pregnant will
defense keeping it
in the center probably Holly right those
two know how he loves the guys there's a
fan of other teams
[Music]
to the corner in Detroit obviously we've
seen erratic dramatic play from him make
one miss one and right there a very
splendid move is the third time this
season he's a double figure rebound
[Applause]
extend dishing lasting sushi making up
for tonight though especially with the
alley oop knocks will try a three
pointer it's that one to go it's his
first three-point attempt he's got nine
points in the mix back within eight
things not blocking out games team he
turns it over
knocks coming in 1 on 2 March gets the
roll
[Applause]
GOx trips free never docks with his
first field goal
so again for Toronto tonight as they
turn it over here comes knocks lays it
up and in and only attempted to three
throw Tim said the have they came from
knocks knocks up with the left hand with
a strong move to the basket
Ellingson picked off the dreaded double
team and then Thompson lost it
here comes Crowder
we've been waiting two seats that type
of scallop equinox warmers tonight watch
the hustle right here you can hate
anything getting back to prison a linear
in the booze he was also 5 back slaps it
down a final five is presented by Ford
as well under the five-minute mark
knocks for three once again late the
game now to get in a nice rhythm by
docks wrapped in swaddling goaltend fans
Lee that's blocked by docks
[Applause]
judge nice continuity spontaneity by
both teams he in his own there Knox gets
Reich sedan take some contact and backs
at all made in three ball and then
really then dealing over at a bottle
very lucid now if the dribble he seen
tonight in good hustle Knox way downtown
that's a three that's the second
three-pointer one's the righty ones a
lefty that's my guess to all say Knox
pax it all looks back up three that was
there for second
the oxen Cornett could be that time we
got to come down and help him out so
that we keep our big Gavin get in foul
trouble thank you Mike thanks Rebecca
knocks has to put up quickly shot clock
winding down and knocks now with 13
points the tree knocks off the triple
looking for some room
nice move from Knox creating a little
space flips it up and in it's on you and
that's a bad shot right back out the
knock so ever Knox jumpers up that's
good 18 for Knox on 7 of 12 from the
field him down the big tee time winding
down there's dogs it's good at the foul
and in the dish will play their season
finale here at the garden against
Detroit on Wednesday as Cornett lays it
in
[Applause]
please look into capitalized as its deal
persona
the highest eels this season as we play
one game
Cornette comes off
when that puts it on the floor lost it
knocks just gets it off the time and
hits it 3/4 for Kevin Hawk says that
let's go up violent and Rick Williams
with the field goal here's Kevin Knox
over Williamson he splashes one home
Vincent a real force in the paint
throughout the regular season for the
Knicks Knox
hit his first three threes hits his
first one here tonight you're in
business
tough shot no good here comes Kadeem
Allen up to Kevin Knox he's got enough
to quick starts in his games and
continues to do so here that's his
second field goal
earned on coaches Appreciation Day this
is a move that any coach would love back
after this him in Mike entire did you
think I mean Frank Frank Vogel mentioned
paycock Indiana busy days Mitchell
Robinson will pogo stick inside there's
getting away bad things are gonna happen
for you defensively and when you help up
my contact yes we didn't know the next
generation will be the Tristan Thompson
the are gay bear a wig and so forth and
so on and you look at all the Canadian
players that's all about it means
there's a time for finesse but if you're
attacking the raft
here's Knox for three puts it in he's
got it great stuff a look at head [ __ ]
Knox disrupted that just enough trying
to get their second win here at Summer
League Knox pitches it out fresh Davis
for three
[Applause]
57 for the game great fine by Knox Bros
Degas uncovered in the corner for three
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content